we are capable of so much more let's
figure out how to unlock the best of our
people today my friend host of the
Fantastic finding Mastery podcast Dr
Michael Jer returns to Mike the single
greatest constrictor of human potential
is fear of other people's opinions we're
masquerading like we are individuals in
a social world starts with I think your
relationship with yourself this thesis
is more fully articulated in his
fantastic first book the first rule of
Mastery the process of using one's
imagination is a real powerhouse it's a
fundamental commitment to work from the
inside out you can do it on your
own it's harder mhm if you are a chronic
people pleaser like myself or you're
just looking to lead a more
self-actualized high performance life
this one is appointment listening you
can think about you as an individual who
do you want to become are you actually
asking me that question right now
[Music]
yeah I'm extremely proud to introduce
you to our newest brand partner on check
out their lineup of super comfortable
sleek and durable pieces for yourself at
[Music]
on.com so good to see you oh it's great
to be here it's been a minute it has
been I think this is the fifth time that
you've done the show though I need to
start with something though oh no I've
been to say this you do this every time
no I do I I've been wanting to say this
too there are a handful of people that
fundamentally shape your life and it was
an experience that you created where you
earnestly said I want to ask you some
questions and there's this thing called
a
podcast and so I was like oh that sounds
good but the way that you shaped our
first conversation the first time we met
was honest it was curious you are
exceptional in what you do but the way
you created that space I felt seen and
understood and valued and it was awesome
and so I said from that moment I said I
want to create that same experience for
other people my friends and so here we
are 8 years later with the fny Mastery
podcast and you are one of those people
that have changed my trajectory so I
want to say thank you I appreciate that
what you've built is is really
impressive and inspirational on its own
right and you know I remember that first
experience and I think it was like in
the it was so early in my journey with
all of this and I was just excited to
meet you and that you said yes you know
I I think I read an outside article
about you and I was like who is this guy
like I want to meet this guy I figured
out how to reach out to you and you
actually agreed to do it so I was
thrilled yeah right oh that's fun I know
that and it ended up being a meaningful
experience for me as well as well as for
the audience and then you reached out
and you're like tell me more about this
podcasting thing and yeah I don't know
how many years ago that was I think it
like
2012 yeah so almost 10 years maybe 2013
wow yeah longer than that could that
more than a decade yeah that's pretty
cool um which is cool and not only did
you go off and and build this amazing
podcast a lot of people say they're
going to start a podcast and a lot of
people do very few stick with it but it
is impressive and on top of that you've
created all of these other kind of
tentacles that are ancillary and related
to what you do on the podcast not the
least of which is reaching out into the
corporate world I think when I first met
you you were operating out of like a
sports medicine clinic in in Marina del
re that's right and today I think how
many people do you employ like 25 30
about F you're doing events all over the
world and your focus has expanded from
Individual athletes Olympians and
professional sports teams to working
with Fortune 500 companies and helping
them learn about leadership and team
building so I guess I'm interested in
what the parallels and differences are
between those two worlds as somebody who
kind of entered into this high
performance niche of
psychology focused in entirely on
athletes from the beginning to now doing
something that's not qualitatively
different but I would imagine in many
ways distinguishable from those earlier
days so let's just like pull back the
curtain a little bit early on I needed
to understand psychology as a young
16-year-old athlete like I needed it I
didn't understand how to get free when
game day was happening I didn't
understand how to have access to my
skills and so you know the term choking
so literally no athletes have ever
choked because we don't eat while we're
performing so there's no real choking
that's that's a bad joke okay we'll just
stay there for a minute but we do choke
off access to our abilities and that is
really how the mind can work it can
choke off your ability to get free to
express to go for it to get on the edge
to be okay with however it goes so I
needed to understand how the best in the
world do that how they get free how they
become their very best sometimes the
best in the world and that led me down
the path of studying the psychology of
sport or the psychology of excellence
and they come to find out after working
20 plus years with those folks there's
this thing that happens in leadership
and in leadership they're they're as
interested in being their very best but
equally if not more important is
creating the right culture and the right
systems for their people to be their
very best so that was the beginnings of
the crosswalk from sport from Team if
you will so it started individual then I
went to team then it started working
with coaches and GMS and ownership and
management and then that was the
crosswalk into uh leadership and
business the parallel and the crosswalk
is pretty rich and so now you have these
large events and you're working with
large team like Microsoft I know you're
public about like working with them and
that seems like a very immersive
relationship that goes all the way to
the top to the CEO down through the
various departments and working with
department heads and how they create
culture and kind of alignment in terms
of purpose which is the theme in the
book that we're going to get to do you
find that there's more overlap between
working with athletes and like team
leaders and corporations than one might
suspect on first clance yeah that's a
fun conversation to have because
initially what I would have thought
would have made a great athlete would
not make a great leader in a corporate
setting however there are certain skills
that do translate and so some of those
similarities are Clarity of vision so
athletes make a fundamental decision on
how they're going to organize their life
and go for the thing that matters to
them it's the fundamental decision that
happens post Vision so it starts with
using your imagination in a way to
create an amazing future the thing that
you want to co-create or bring into the
world doesn't have to be about yourself
athletes tend to think a little bit more
about themselves but the idea of it
starting with a vision then making
fundamental decisions to build the
capacities the necessary skills to make
that happen that's kind of the basic
mechanics and so I don't want even want
to lose track that the process of using
one's imagination is a real powerhouse
and if we don't invest in it it can run
wild and we lead to anxiety and
depression and other ailments that take
place with an unexamined
uncultivated way of using one's mind and
when you invest in it and cultivate and
harness and garden your own inner
world you can have a sense of freedom
and you can achieve extraordinary
outcomes so it does begin in some
respects with the vision that you that
you create mhm it would seem that that
in the corporate context imagination is
something that's under indexed on you
know what I mean it's not like I think
for many people maybe not you but for
many for many of us really do we really
want our workers spending a lot of time
indulging in their imaginations what we
need them to do is XYZ and perform and
hit these metrics okay so that is the
extraction model the origins of that is
like the Industrial Revolution sit on
this conveyor belt and do this thing
repeatedly and do it faster and so I'm
going to extract the best of you it
started there and then it moved into
something a little bit more you know
cognitive and mental in the way that
people are leading and thinking using
their mind rather than just kind of a
widget on a on a conveyor belt and what
we ended up doing to folks for many
years is extracting the best of them at
the cost of knowing their family at the
cost of living the full life with
flourishing and a sense of zest and so
they gave into the company rather than
pouring into the loved ones so the
extraction model is going the way of the
dodo and we're moving to the unlock
where the best and deepest and brightest
cultivators like satin Nadella at
Microsoft is that they're saying no the
potential lies dormant in our people so
let's figure out this is his remit to to
me and the company finding Mastery let's
figure out how to unlock the best of our
people where there's purpose they know
their purpose we know our purpose we
align purposes where we help them
understand how to be calm how to have a
sense of energy inside of themselves to
meet the demands of the moment where
they know how to have a sense of
optimism about about what could be
instead of being whipped around by the
the thrashing of the external world and
all the dangers that ensue and all the
risks and stresses and pressures let's
work from the inside out and so that is
basically taking the psychology of
excellence and cascading it through an
organization that's new leadership
that's modern leadership understanding
how to apply psychology because it's no
longer the extraction and don't think
the new language of programming is human
language all the coding that's that's
happening is changing right it's no
longer Python and this that and the
other we're all going to be coders here
in the next five years and it's the way
that we use our thoughts and our words
and if they can align with our actions
we've got something very powerful and so
we are literally coding the future
future as we go and if people
are unfulfilled and UNF flourished I
don't know if we're going to get to the
place we want to go to well certainly
it's a better long-term strategy and it
begins with a change in how you relate
to an employee not as a fungible object
that can be replaced like a widget on a
conveyor belt but as a fully fleshed out
human being with all their own desires
and fears and motivations Etc how do you
create a culture where people are
excited to come to work and they feel
like they can do their best work and
flourish and they're seen for who they
are which is a fundamental shift in kind
of how the workplace operates and you
see it when you go into forward leaning
companies and you can taste it and smell
it and see it it's very palpable like I
was in Zurich not too long ago and I
went to the headquarters for on on
running was a big partner of ours I
think you've done some stuff with them
did and it's just extraordinary when you
go into a place like that and everyone
is working you know at a different level
they're totally engaged with what
they're doing you can sense that they
feel empowered and that they have agency
over you know certain like areas of
decision-making that make them feel very
connected to the work that they're doing
and it's inspiring to see that and it
shifts fundamentally how you know kind
of whatever conventional perception you
have about the workplace and supplants
that like cubic idea with a whole new
idea of what a workplace can be you're
feeling exactly the thing that I'm
talking about you can get there by
accident you know like that can happen
but that's not my experience it's like
really intentional and very thoughtful
and let's say
1980 executive team would get together
maybe a you know big firm consultancy
would come in and they'd shape their
culture and they'd have their values and
they would have their mission and
purpose and they put them on you know
big stickers on walls right or maybe
even make them some sort of emblem on on
whatever so words in the hallways is not
how it works like words on walls is not
how this works that's good it's the
beginnings of wanting to create
something
special but the leaders really become
Chief repeating officers about what
we're pointing toward being honest about
leading from the values and virtues that
the organization has established to be
important and
then having the real resource of
psychological skills be part of the
rhythm of business let me mat back that
last piece is
significant big sport is about 10 to 15
years ahead of big business right so in
big sport Elite Sport 10 to 15 years ago
let's go 15 years ago you can go 50
years back even to Modern Times And you
ask a coach or an athlete is the mental
part of the game important and what do
they say of course of course it is and
then 15 years ago okay so what are you
doing to invest in it and they'd say
well we've we've got a sport py now like
across the hall or across the um town
and I think some athletes you know go to
him or her mhm or that's where they go
when they fall off a cliff that was like
15 years crisis management right yeah
okay so then go like 10 years ago you
ask the same question is important they
go yeah yeah of course and we've
actually got someone in the building
that's not good enough it's good but not
good enough and now it's up to
leadership to say hey this is rad this
is a competitive Advantage invest in you
we see you as a full person go get this
thing it's going to show up on the field
it's going to show up at home like go
invest in you we want you to be your
very best but the onus is still on the
individual to take that up that's right
so leadership creates air cover and if
they do that right you get a little bit
of backfill from the athletes or the
individuals to go invest extra Okay now
what's happening if you pull back the
curtain on Elite performing organization
in sport psychology is in the rhythm of
business it's in the hallways it's in
practice it's folded into to the way
weights are moved the way that bodies
are moved during practice it's in film
room it's on the sidelines it's on the
bus it's folded into the rhythm of
business and that's where we're pointing
hopefully for modern business is to put
it in the rhythm of business and what
does that look like specifically like my
only kind of cultural reference point is
watching bil and seeing that character
who has her office in there and all the
Traders come in and she helps them you
know sort of get their head straight so
that they can be high performers and she
certainly plays a crucial role like
she's indispensable in their success
equation but in the context of something
like Microsoft or these other companies
that you're working with like is there
somebody who's stationed there all the
time like how do you weave that in so
that it just is a piece with their
workday and part of the culture like on
some level you're performing a bit of an
Inception right because it's one thing
for the boss to say this is our purpose
and then you have people who are like
look man this is just my job like you
want me to tell you that that's my
purpose too fine I'll tell you that like
is it really my purpose is really my
family and I'm just here to make some
money that's where you start to get some
breakdown in things and that's okay that
is really okay if that's the case for
the person your point is well taken or
your question is well taken which is
like how does it really work the
billions model is cool it's working with
the influencers and the decision makers
at the head of the organization and it's
still kind of a one-off model like go
into that wonderful room that's a little
scary you know and work it's still like
a therapeutic session that's right
that's good not great so what great is
this is my bias of course right is that
what I was able to do with uh the
Seattle Seahawks and the head coach
coach Carol is we would work the coaches
so the the coaches would be hydrated
with psychological skills themselves and
then the extension is we'd show them or
I would show them how to pass that on to
their athletes so no longer like old
sports psychology is I'll tell you the
story when I first got my first team I
was part of head coach goes this is
going to be great I got someone for you
to work with and I'll tell you what if
you can make a difference it was hockey
if you can make a difference with
him like man we'll be a lot better and H
like if you could make a different I
didn't realize this was the quote
unquote Head Case across that's how they
thought of this athlete High Talent
extraordinarily gifted good work ethic
but just couldn't quite figure out how
to get free and be confident and there
was that choking thing I was talking
about and then because of that tension
they thrash that's what happens like
when you're unsettled you know this
better than anybody you start to thrash
and relationships are compromised and
you're caught in a little bit of a a
swirl in the culture if you will and you
can't get those noses and toes pointed
in the same direction so I was like okay
put me in coach like oh great so now I'm
walking down the hallway with that
person and the other athletes and
everyone else in the organization was
like oh if you're talking to JY I guess
you're a head case that's old that that
can't work anymore it's pathologized
that's right so then a little bit better
is like when the coach says look I want
you to work with the absolute best and
he's excited or she's excited and now
you start to pair sport psychology with
competitive Advantage you know leading
from the front if you're not doing that
you're kind of getting left behind a
little bit so that's a bit better the
ideal mechanism is when the coaches or
the leaders in the
organization understand how to practice
five mental skills let's say and they
know how to teach and translate those
these are basic these are not complex
breathing is not complex there's some
complexity to the actual mechanics but
teaching it is not hard to do but
carving Out 3 minutes at the top of
agenda for your organization to
downregulate that is an exponential
moment for organizations to do it across
a company we're going to downregulate
for three minutes let's say um across
200,000 people in our Organization three
times a day oh competitive Advantage hit
and so that's what we're doing at the
Seattle Seahawks is working with a coach
is making sure that they were well
hydrated with psychological skills and
they knew how to translate it and pass
it on to the athletes right and so now
you're laying that template in a
corporate landscape and doing something
similar and what's happening in the
corporate world is that we have
invisible limits we have blind spots we
have things that because we're so mired
in the culture that it's hard to see
them and so one of the great gifts that
somebody outside of yourself can give
give you is like hey have you ever
noticed like what what do you think like
could this be something that's a little
bit of a struggle for you like oh yeah
like we've been banging our heads on
that for a while oh okay well here's a
way to think about maybe solving that
and then we backfill it with
psychological skills so it's like it's
it's not again it's not complicated but
humans are complex but it is a total
reframe if you're walking into a
conventional organization where where
you know basically the employees
underneath a certain department head are
being driven almost entirely by making
sure that their jobs are in good stead
and that they have the approval of the
department head and are kind of
acquitting their their responsibilities
in accordance with those expectations
irrespective of whether they think it's
a good idea or not like and that kind of
calcifies any kind of evolution of a
corporate entity right I would think
that that's like a a major Peril for
most companies when they reach a certain
size and scale that's where you know the
Reinventing is really important and
constantly staying on that front edge of
who are we becoming and are we being
honest with the resources we're
providing people and you can think about
you as an individual who do you want to
become who do I want to become are you
actually asking me that question I
thought about like just letting it be
rhetoric and then I saw your eyes light
up and I thought let me just pause yeah
who who do you want to become derail
your point you can Circle back to that
but so you can ask it as an individual
and then you can also ask it at the team
level or the organizational level and
that's that starts with like using your
imagination who are you working on
becoming and without that without a
vision or a set of bell weathers to be
able to know if you're lining up your
thoughts words and actions in alignment
with that purpose or that
Vision the external world will own you
it will pull you it will stress you it
will create U distractions if we don't
know how to work from the inside out we
will play and live life on the terms of
other people and that's really dangerous
and I think that people are tired of it
that's the great opportunity I think
right now for people is to say who do
you want to become backfill it with the
psychological skills to help you be
about it and then do what athletes do
every day is amongst and with people
that are wanting to take their job their
friends their peers and somebody that
wants their position on the team and
coaches that determine if they're going
to get playtime or not that every day
they are going to the messy
Edge at that place where they could fall
into a thousand pieces or unlock
something special and they go there
every day amongst those that want their
job know what's good what's ugly what's
not acceptable even in front of people
that can decide you're with us or you're
not the NFL stands for not for long and
what they do not really but what those
athletes do is a radical risk-taking
every day incredibly vulnerable and we
look at them and think like they're kind
of born that way but we don't do that we
don't go every day and get to our
emotional Edge we play it safe we play
it small we get busy as opposed to
intentional we lie to oursel numb oursel
and we stay on the surface rather than
going to the places that they go which
is right at that edge where they could
fall apart or be just right in the
presence of a slipstream of unlocking
something special the next level of
their expression that is to be
[Music]
regarded every athlete I know is going
to tell you that having the right gear
is key to Performance if what you're
wearing is poorly crafted it's just
going to put distance between you and
those goals you've set you owe it to
yourself to invest in the best and the
best is on I'm obsessed with the cloud
Ultra right on the trails and I just got
the new NextGen Cloud Stratus 3 for the
road I'm loving those but on also has
this incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously dawned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra te and the ultra shorts which have
this pocket right at the base of the
spine that perfectly anchors your phone
no jiggle I'm just so proud to partner
with on and I love their vision for the
future where their gear is engineered
for
circularity so check out their amazing
lineup of super comfortable sleek and
durable pieces for yourself at
on.com in order to
Foster a culture or an environment that
is not only permissive for people to
walk up to that edge but actually
encourages it is a special thing right
and that's almost like a hat trick in
the corporate world right how do you
create a culture where there isn't a
fear of reprisal if you extend yourself
perhaps beyond your remit to do
something special or to express your
purpose and feel safe in doing that like
there's a safety net and that this is
something that's encouraged rather than
discouraged when you said hat trick do
you mean like you scored three goals or
like I mean like a very difficult thing
to accomplish or achieve oh I think
you're
spoton and we say in the corporate world
we you know people say fail fast fail
forward fail often failures where you
learn but that's not reality yeah if
they do that they'll be you know taken
to task for that's right and in sport
that's what practice is really about
getting to that edge two stories here I
asked an
Olympian looks like she's going to be uh
competing in 2024 in Paris so she was an
Olympian last year she remade the team
and I said what is a great practice for
you and she says oh very clearly top of
the tongue She says um knowing what I
need to get better at so every practice
she goes into her day getting to the
edge to see where things break down to
know what she needs to get better at so
if if I were to ask you I don't want to
put you on the spot but if I were to ask
somebody like you what do you need to
get better at and again it's not
necessarily how athletes do what they do
because that it's pretty special how
they move but the intentionality to be
very clear about what they're working on
getting better at and if I were to say
physically let's play the game I can use
me in this as well and I say where's the
pain in your body and you'd say um I
don't know my left hip where's the pain
in your body I have no idea my lower
back low back right and I say how are
you working on your low back you'd say I
have a couple practitioners that I see
and a whole series of exercises that I
do and all kinds of proactive sort of
little things that I do throughout the
day to ameliorate the pain and you know
yeah and you you've got a plan yeah and
you're working it and then I say great
emotionally or mentally what are you
working on H oh so many things okay so
pause yeah it just feels different to
talk about it we're still in that kind
of place where it's a little bit more
it's definitely more invisible the world
of psychology is invisible but didn't it
feel just a little different to say oh
I'm working on less depression less
anxiety more joy whatever it might be
did it feel that way for you yeah
there's definitely a little bit more
constriction and I say that as somebody
who's pretty open about this stuff like
most people aren't I have no problem
telling you like oh you know I need to
work on being a better friend or I need
to let go of my perfectionism and like I
succumb to you know all manner of the
things that you talk about in this book
to this day you know like like this was
written for me in so many ways like how
do I divorce myself from so many of the
lures that I know are leading me astray
and at times I feel powerless to combat
like I'm comfortable even publicly
talking about this kind of stuff but I'm
also very aware that that is not the
usual case with most people yeah so just
getting Heroes like you in the world
that are the cool kids waving their arms
saying heyy I'm working physically and
I'm working on the emotional side and
both are matter to me and I can talk
about both and I have a plan to work
both that's what great athletes do is
they're clear about what they want to
unlock and get better at and they have a
plan to back it up whether it's
technical physical or mental and then
the failing thing to your earlier point
you know I was with Formula 1 for a
handful of years and new leader comes in
new managing director comes in into the
team has 500 of the brightest Engineers
you know as part of the team and he's
addressing the full team and these are
engineers and computer scientists and
and and from MIT and Harvard and like
Brilliant Minds behind the scenes of the
driver and so he addresses his vision he
addresses how he wants to go about
creating a culture and um what he thinks
the reasonable goals are and the lofty
goals and has this beautiful kind of
moment because it's called 30 minutes on
the factory floor sharing it all and um
people nod you know uhhuh and then one
engineer stands and he claps a little
bit longer than everyone else and people
are starting to walk away and he's got a
little slow clap and he's looking at the
new
boss and uh the boss makes eye contact
with him and the boss
says what's going on like a slow clap
like a mocking slow clap kind yeah he
says yeah and the engineer says those
are good
words and so the leader says to me he
goes I knew right then I had to be about
it because I was going to be called out
I was going to be held to a standard I
needed to lead from authenticity so he
goes into the post first race and after
the first race fail fast fail forward
fail off and da D he says um okay
everybody there was a tough race I want
to talk about the two mistakes I know I
made and I need to get better I don't
know if anyone else saw them but I made
this mist mistake here and this mistake
here I know how to solve the first one I
need your help on how to solve the
second one it's a blind spot for me I
don't know how to do it that's my report
who's up set the standard right there
didn't prep anyone for it but held the
standard that we all make mistakes and
if we're going to the messy Edge that's
going to happen that's how the unlocks
take place and you and I don't have to
do it physically or in a race car we can
do it emotionally every day it can
happen in conversations with friends or
loved ones about what's really happening
about what really is going on inside and
when you do that that messy Razor's Edge
is so alive and so scary you could fall
into a thousand pieces or unlock the
relationship that you wanted to have
with that person beautifully put I think
most people's and I would include myself
in this default setting is to double
down on the things that we're good at
and you know blind ourselves to our weak
spots and the elite athlete has that
reflex to move towards the weaknesses
because they understand that their
performance is going to be dictated by
developing those weaknesses into
strengths but in our day-to-day lives
we're not necessarily compelled or
challenged in a way that kind of pushes
us towards our weaknesses and it's very
easy to just keep doing the thing that
we know we're good at and kind of hold
those weaknesses over here and pretend
they don't exist or that they're not
really undermining you know who we want
to be there's lots of ways to go after
what you're talking about as a tactic
the way I like to work with folks
remember my training is in sport
psychology the psychology of excellence
and if you think about all the skills
that go into you being your very best
maybe even great at something say we
have a list of nine there's usually more
but this is just for the sake of
conversation there's three you're really
good at it three that are you know
you're pretty good and then three that
relatively uh struggle with now those
bottom three might be better than 99% of
the world but those are a relative stack
just as a thought experiment if you were
working with an athlete on whether it's
physical technical or mental stack that
we're talking about of skills where
would you start would you help them be
better like Shaquille O'Neal Let's help
you be a better Force underneath the
basket or obviously when he played he
was terrible at free throw shooting
right he really struggled there would
you help him on his free throw or would
you help him on something in the middle
in order to answer that question you
need a more comprehensive kind of road
map or blueprint of how that person
operates because if there's some kind of
mental tweak perhaps that needs to be
addressed fundamentally first before you
even get to the free throw thing I like
that I like that so let's assume that
this person is a great learner they want
to get after it they're okay being in
the messy Edge you know let's just
assume that they're a good learner this
is just philosophic
you know for tactics would you start
with reinforcing what they're great at
what they're okay with or what they
struggle with with what they struggle
with yeah that's what I thought you were
going based on the last part of your
conversation and there's no right or
wrong here where I go is right in the
middle of the stack and I go towards the
top of the middle so I'll go to number
four and the reason I go to number four
is because now there's this like
interesting slipstream that I found for
folks is that they start working on
something and they become better at it
because they're close to being good at
it they become better at that and
they're like
oh oh like I can get better at some
other stuff too and so then you start
moving down the stack that's how I go
about it so that's interesting but I
would have thought and part of the
reason why I said the weak thing let's
use free throws as the example is
because they're so bad at that there's
much more room for improvement and and
the velocity of that Improvement seems
like an easier lift that would create
that encouragement and that level of
Engagement with their own ability to
change and evolve I think that that is
super reasonable and I've seen that show
up plenty of times what happens
privately is they're like oh man I'm not
very good at free thr thing they hate so
they're dreading it now we've got a
spotlight on the thing that they don't
like fine that's totally fine to do but
then there's this hyperfixation on
things I'm not good at and that's not
the psychology that got them there the
psychology got them there was like I'm a
force underneath the basket give me the
Rock and if we start to shift that to
focus on the things are not good at
solely or Majora ofely then the
psychology starts to change like man
maybe I'm never going to be able to
unlock this like I'm not good at this
that's interesting so it's an
interesting just potential pivot between
where you go that makes a lot of sense
isn't that kind of fun just as a thought
stem to think through but fundamentally
and you referenced this a minute ago is
this pre set or our kind of fundamental
disposition around how we interface with
our own sense of purpose our own value
set and what motivates us are we
extrinsically motivated or are we
internally driven and this provides the
foundation for this book your first book
congratulations thank you which is all
about like liberating yourself from the
opinions of others and turning that
Spotlight inward to try to understand
what what your purpose is what your
value set is and creating a structure
where you're driven internally in
accordance with those to kind of mute
out the extraneous noise of the outside
world as a road map towards Mastery and
I guess the first question that I would
ask you is like of all the things like
Mastery is your world your podcast is
called finding Mastery like this is what
you obsess about and think about and
practice and teach is it this kind of
subject terrain that's providing the on
wrap to your very first book like you
could have picked a lot of ways to
communicate your ideas around Mastery
but you're focused on this very singular
concept as kind of an introduction to
your world and how you think about high
performance I love the question because
I think a lot of people are quietly
asking themselves D why'd you write a
book on this and I appreciate that
you're actually asking it many people
have not asked this question it seems
like the obvious first question yeah
it's cool yeah good so I'll tell you the
the reason being because I think it is
the greatest constrictor of one's
potential I think this
obsessive private worry about what
somebody else is thinking about me is
the great unnamed unexamined constrictor
of potential and it is like David Foster
Wallace shared in his poem there's three
fish there's an old fish swimming one
way and two young fish swimming the
other way and the old fish uh as he
passes by says morning boys how's the
water and the two young fish swim on and
then one Brave of the young fish says to
the other the hell is water and I I
think that's what is happening it's like
this navigation of am I being accepted
by others am I being rejected by others
is the water that we are swimming in it
is so foundational to safety and
survival that that we've almost forgot
to label it we've got the fight flight
freeze mechanism to ready us without
even having to think from a Waring tribe
from a wilderbeast from a saber-tooth
tiger from whatever is perceived to be
dangerous we don't even have to think in
our body readies and that's because our
brain is optimized for
survival belonging is safety belonging
is survival so there's this other
General thing that's taking place in our
brain the 3.2 pounds of tissue that is
it's scanning the world for things that
are dangerous and trying to figure out
how to be okay and one of the great
dangers the near-death sentence is if
you and I are in a tribe let's go back
200,000 years ago and Rich and Mike are
doing their thing and let's say that I
don't know you sharpen the arrows and I
I got the bows just right and each time
we go hunting we come back and ARS are
broken and we miss our Target and the
tribe is is hungry and let's say another
time we're out Gathering and I'm coming
back with rotten whatever and like
you're off you know doing something else
in your add moment you don't come back
with the right berries either over time
underperformance has led to rejection
and once we're kicked out of the tribe
that rejection is a near death sentence
because you and I can't forge and fend
and fight and Hunt and Gather just the
two of us or maybe our spouses maybe
like three kids and then maybe a cousin
and an uncle it's too much so
safety is part of belonging and so what
ends up happening we've got this General
mechanism in our brain to take the
temperature of other people to make sure
that we're okay in their eyes well that
getting kicked out of the tribe now is
no longer a death sentence or near death
sentence it's just doesn't feel good so
but we still have the mechanism to tune
to see if we're okay in the eyes of
other people because we are petrified to
be rejected and that's what's happening
and I was 16 years old I saved up enough
money to buy my first car there's a
Mazda b2000 pickup truck I could throw
my surfboard in the back and I felt
great about it it was like a $2,000
truck and there was a car driving and
they were on my left-hand side they were
were going the same direction they were
going to pass me and I remember sitting
up grabbing the steering wheel like a
cool kid would and thinking to myself
they're going to see how cool I am in my
new car like I'm going to show up right
in this moment so as they're passing me
I look to the left and they didn't care
they didn't even look they had no clue
that I existed I did not matter at all
to them and I had this lightning bulb
moment what am I doing with my life I'm
a 16-year-old kid and I'm having this
existential Moment Like This is
embarrassing I just did all of this
performance to be looked at by somebody
favorably that I didn't even know what
is that and I was so embarrassed by it I
didn't talk about it I just kept it
private and I knew that I was doing it
throughout my life and I was so
embarrassed that I was playing a
secondary game and socially I was fine I
could fit in in a lot of places and it
helps when dad's an alcoholic and Mom's
codependent you got to figure out how to
navigate there's an interesting brew
that creates
a psychologist right yeah and so you
figure out how to tune to others but I
was doing it a lot
and then come to sit with best in the
world and they talk about like not
letting others down not wanting to blow
it not wanting to da da da da and
there's just all this narrative about
how important the opinions of others is
to their life and well-being and sense
of self so I wrote an article and the
article was on hbr 12 months later and
it was on this like this number one
constrictor this obsessiveness about how
you're perceived by others
and they called me 12 months after and
they
said uh you're the number one downloaded
article oh wow so you hit a read it it's
great yeah thank you I didn't look at
the date on it I was just assuming that
came out after the book as part of like
getting the book out into the world no
that happened well before like three
years ago wow so they called and they
said let's write a book and I was like
man I'm wrestling alligators right now
like life is hard I do not have that
bandwidth to do it and they said no
problem let's come back around and I was
like thank you they called 12 months
later and they said it was number one
downloaded again like there's a real
nerve here so I felt like I wasn't
alone I wasn't alone with this obsessive
worry that kept me safe but small that
kept me playing the second game that
didn't have a sense of freedom in it and
I had shed a lot of it because I'd
worked at it a long time I still have
some of it I'm not free from it
completely like I'm not the enlightened
one here that's you definitely not yeah
so don't play that game with me I know
what you're doing I'm still working at
it and come to find out I'm not alone
just naming it is healthy for people
well I think what's brilliant about that
it's not surprising that that that that
hidden nerve and by hbr you mean the the
Harvard Business Review
because there's two things going on like
it does provide this lens into the world
of Mastery which is your specialty but
it's also something that almost all of
us can relate to it's a Universal
experience so whether you're interested
in Mastery or not or perhaps you're just
curious about the human condition and
the human psyche in general like this is
something that we can all find
commonality around because I think it
just it imperils and kind of affects us
in various ways throughout our life like
that story that you told I have many
versions of that and you know worrying
about other people's opinions I've gone
through acute stages of my life where
that was very paralyzing yes it's a
vestage of this evolutionary trait that
kept us alive but it's also very hard to
shake and today you know I shouldn't be
concerned about these things at all but
it still you know kind of commanders me
in certain ways that I wish it didn't
and I think that now because of social
media and the way that we kind of
interface with each other in our digital
lives it's more acute than ever and it's
also a very you know kind of tricky Town
Square that we all inhabit where being
ostracized from the village kind of does
feel real like you say the wrong thing
and then suddenly there's a you know
cascading set of consequences that can
actually spill out into the real world
and affect you in in dramatic and
negative ways and I think it has
everybody's spincter tightened a little
bit you know and like thinking long and
hard about what they're going to say or
not say and there's that sense of
constriction like how do I how do I do
this how do I interface with this and I
think it's put us in contact with that
ingrained impulse that we have around
how we you know participate as as a
community and what is the real threat
versus the perceived threat amen that
sense of community we are more like a
coral reef than a nail banged into a
board as an individual sense of self
like we are more like a COR we we need
each other in so many different
dimensional ways and it's not just like
oh I don't want to be caught saying
something that I'm going to piss off
other people so I'm going to monitor
myself there's a function of that
certainly or it's also what can I say
that's going to get the court of opinion
clapping in my direction that's okay yes
on both of those and then I do think
that the fear of rejection is more
important than than the desire to be
accepted so I think the fear of
rejection is the stronger motivator
however I think it shows up in our
relationships with our parents even as
adults I think it shows up
you know to this this is why we get
pissed off because I'm like how many
decisions have you made to impress
either your mother or your father over
the course of your life that were not
necessarily in alignment with your own
sense of purpose it's gross why am I
doing that I can answer it as a
psychologist as a self- examined
psychologist the other piece is like I
think we do with our spouses we do with
our friends so these are Intimate
Relationships it's not just performing
for
them it's about is she going to be okay
if I say this m now what I need to do is
go back to my first principles and am I
going to be about my first principles or
conform or contort them for the approval
of the person that has demonstrated like
I'm in it with you like let's do the
long-term thing here let's really know
each other and go deep let's build a
life together and still am I conforming
in some kind of way to not piss off or
upset set the apple cart or you know
like it shows up in super slippery ways
yeah and those really subtle ways that
perhaps are the most nefarious that's it
yeah so there's Freedom there is a
better way and part of that is like know
whose opinions really matter to you for
me I need a round table of eight MH you
could have 12 you could have four you
know but like what is your Round Table
what is the criteria for them to be at
your round table and for me it's twofold
happy to share them but love to hear
yours like what would be the criteria of
the people to be at your round table
that you you say listen your opinion
matters to me deeply well I have
different people for different areas of
my life so I have a round table around
my sobriety I have a different Round
Table around things like parenting
professional decisions that I have to
make relationship stuff there's
different people that I call on for
different reasons and I would say say
it's more than eight but I don't know
that I've defined it and written it down
and said this is my Round Table yeah but
you know I go to AA and I have different
round taes of people who are very
important to me that help keep me on
track and that are a sounding board for
many of my decisions I have a formal
men's group every week that I sit down
with a group of eight guys and that's
where we share non sobriety oriented
stuff in my case around you know
parenting dilemmas that I butt up
against or relationship stuff I've been
with my wife 23 years like what does
this look like now how do I keep this
alive and how do we stay you know
energized in our marriage and you know
continue to cultivate that level of
intimacy or I have a big professional
decision I need to make like I only
share those decisions with a very select
group of people that I'm very
intentional about you know that like I
don't you don't just spew it out and let
everybody's opinions roll in that's
right that creates paralysis and
confusion and you're over indexing on
certain PE because everybody's got an
opinion about everything right so now
more than ever like you go online God
forbid you share like should I do this
online like you're going to get a
zillion different opinions from who
knows who these people are and on top of
that are we really meant to know
everybody's opinion on everything all
the time every second of every single
day like it doesn't make me feel good
like it could be fun to Source there can
be some wisdom in crowdsourcing like
create a poll or something like that but
I think it's much more effective to
identify the people who you really trust
who you know have your best interest at
heart and are going to really
consider the question at hand and aren't
afraid to give you the hard answer okay
so these are the criteria whatever table
it might be we're having a similar
criteria the ones when I thought deeply
about it is there's two vectors one is
they have built time under tension with
me and I know that they care I know that
they have an understanding of my micro
and massive traumas in my life they have
context to the person who I want to
become and be more often it's not an
opinion that's out of context and
they've demonstrated with time under
tension that they really care about my
well-being and then on this other side
it's they've been in the
amphitheater where there's real stress
and pressure and they know the defaults
that happen in those conditions so it's
the context of both of those that I go
I'm at home I can be so vulnerable that
you know how to take care of me in my
most vulnerable state because you know
you know the person I want to be and you
know the traumas I've had so it's in
context MH and like my wife is my best
friend we've been married 28 years and
people used to ask me early in my career
Arc like what are the commonalities or
what are the traits of the great like
what are the ones that hang together it
was something that I thought deeply
about and I did a lot of Investigation
around it and I'm less interested in
answering that and I'm more interested
in pointing to who are your trusted
Partners like forget about what they do
who has your back unconditionally
positive regard sees you knows you and
is going to ride with you to help you be
your very best even when it's hard and
there's a reason 50% of marriages or
more fall apart right because the depth
is not taken care of and this is the
depth that I'm talking about watering
and knowing so those are the criteria
for me they care and they understand
what it feels like to be in high
pressured yeah and that understanding
Demands a level of experience in
whatever it is that you're running by
them and vulnerability you have to bring
you into the conversation if you and I
just beer and pizza should I do this or
this yeah I don't right yeah I've never
shared like my ache with you then it's
out of context you're just staying at
the surface with the beer pizza and
chicken wings whatever kind of
conversation that's just I know that you
don't do beer pizza chicken wings I
understand you know but just for fun the
surface level conversation sure so if
somebody's listening to this and this is
a new idea for them how does one go
about corralling their own Round Table
okay like you could just borrow maybe
those two vectors like who's
demonstrated that they really care or
the beginnings of that maybe you want to
give them a seat and that they have a
sense of what it's like to be in heavy
environments because that's where we
fall apart okay so just some some sort
of semblance of those two and then what
I would say is start with that exercise
then move to one of the three best
practices to know yourself better
mindfulness journaling or conversations
with people of wisdom start with one of
those so that you can work increasing
awareness of how you work from the
inside out one of those three are great
practices and then I would examine the
performance-based identity that you
might be inhabiting MH so we live in
this performance obsessed World
certainly in the west it makes perfect
sense that for Generations we have a
performance-based identity which is
examined by I am what I do and how well
I do what I do as opposed to I am me I
am who I am rather than what I do so
examine the performance-based identity
we take a deep dive in the book on this
but the crosswalk is from
performance-based Identity to
purpose-based Identity what is your
purpose get crystal clear with what your
purpose in life is I would triple down
on
[Music]
that Julie what would you say to
somebody who comes to you and says you
know what I find your lifestyle or the
way that you eat really aspirational but
I'm too busy I just don't have time I
don't want to be cracking open cookbooks
and trying to learn a new skill when I'm
already exhausted after a long day how
do you guide this person where should
they go the plant power meal planner is
really really such an amazing value it
is under $2 a week and for that it gives
you this inspiration knowhow and
thousands of recipes to create the
plant-based meals that you crave in your
own life so it's so amazing to be able
to log on to the plant power meal
planner and get the recipes the
ingredients uh the shopping list and
then the support from all of the coaches
that we have available to answer all of
your questions so join us in eating more
healthy vibrant plant-based meals and to
Kickstart our health intentions this New
Year we're offering you $20 off a
one-year membership with the code power
20 throughout the entire month of
January to learn more and to sign up go
to meals. roll.com again that's promo
code power20 for $20 off at meals. Rich
roll.com
so a couple things so switching to
purpose is essentially what you're
saying is the path going from somebody
who is extrinsically motivated to
internally driven yeah that's how you
bridge that Gap but when you use the
purpose with a capital P that flues a
lot of people that's paralyzing in its
own right I don't know what my purpose
is you're telling me Oh I can't do
anything until I know what my purpose is
what is my purpose and you could spend
years you know chewing the cut on that
and making no progress so how do you get
somebody off the dime on trying to
figure out what that is in their own
life thin slicing I agree with you the
the Magnificent you know exploration of
my grand purpose in life can feel very
overwhelming okay so bring it way down
you know and fin slicing is like what is
my purpose today and just practice that
a week two weeks a month no whatever but
practice thin slicing what is my purpose
today what is the thing that matters to
me that has meaning and it's a little
bit bigger than me and I'm going to need
all day to get this thing kind of
delivered or done so those are the three
criteria for purpose it has personal
meaning it's bigger than you and it's
future oriented so if you thought about
in the most time bound way the thinnest
slice you could what is my purpose today
practice that until you're kind of ready
like what is my purpose for this week
this is not a goal there not goals it's
not checklist purpose has like a soul to
it what is my purpose for this week and
then after you've practiced week purpose
for well move up to month move up to
quarter move up to year and then you
know as you're doing that it will happen
maybe just trust my words for a little
bit like it will happen if you practice
just about anything but if you practice
this you'll become more familiar with it
you'll feel the fabric of that question
and your grand life purpose will become
just a bit more clear one of the
challenges in answering that question I
think tracks back to an amazing Insight
that you share the book that really
struck me which is that our relationship
with this idea of purpose is driven in
the west by this rugged individualism
kind of notion as opposed to it's true
context which is that purpose is
revealed in our relationship with others
and when we think about the context of
our own community and the kind of
Dynamics in which we operate that is a
more fertile soil to kind of Imagine
purpose and develop it as opposed to I'm
here standing alone it's me and Manifest
Destiny you know and I'm going to stake
my claim and this is my purpose and it's
just up to me because that's you know
back to the evolutionary thing like you
say in the book we are not individuals
who have learned to be social we are
social animals who have learned to
identify as separate selves and you know
that is like at the Crux of not just the
purpose conundrum but this whole notion
that drives fear of other people's
opinions yeah we're
masquerading like we are individuals in
a in a social world like we've kind of
got the ordering sideways here and so if
you think about a pebble in a pond and
you think about the Ripple that takes
place from that at the center is your
relationship with yourself this is how I
see it at least in my simple way some
people might say your relationship with
God starts at the center I put your
relationship with yourself there and if
it's informed by God great but it's the
relationship with yourself then the next
ring you could decide what you put in
the next rings but it is about
relationships with and I go with
experience with other people with Mother
Nature with machines and so there's
relationships that are at the foundation
of this whole thing of life and I don't
have this exactly dialed in yet but I'm
thinking that one of the ways I want to
express Mastery of self is a love of
affair with the unfolding
unpredictable unknown present moment if
you could have a love affair with the
unfolding Present Moment Like There's a
sense of real you use your word from
earlier agency and efficacy and a sense
of power and a sense of not needing
controls but giving into the unfolding
present moment and having a love affair
with that unknown that to me I think is
Mastery of self but that is a
relationship with experience and so
starts with I think your relationship
with
yourself to get there you need a couple
other things that you talk about in the
book which is you know a learner's kind
of approach to the world you can call it
a growth mindset and
curiosity yeah so we all have seeds we
all we're more like a gardener than than
we are just about anything else and what
are we tilling what are we tending to
and if we're tending to learning we're
tending to explore we're tending to
figuring things out then those plants
grow those seeds they grow so I I think
that most of us and I'll talk about
myself here for a minute uh for much of
my life I was critical hard on myself I
was judgmental I was pessimistic I was
tilling those seeds and they were
growing and so before I knew it I was
first year in college and I was waking
up to brush my teeth and my hands were
shaking I didn't know what it was I
didn't know that I was living with
anxiety I had no idea what that was I
was wondering is this a neurological
thing like what's going on and I was
racing in my day because I was not
enough and if we take on the gardener
analogy and and we just take a moment
like what are you tilling and what are
you hydrating and what are you growing
what seeds are you cultivating inside of
yourself I think there's a rich metaphor
to be played forward and um I want to be
more Curious than a learner because
there's so much good stuff that I don't
understand and I'm fascinated by making
connections with people with self with
ideas so I've just got to show up and be
a learner it's a more joyous liberated
way to live it's not a new idea though
right I know but it's so hard to access
like when I look at let's just drill
down on this idea of the
performance-based identity this gets
expressed in three negative ways a
contingent selfworth meaning like your
selfworth is basically dependent upon
what other people say it is Al looming
fear of failure Doom is just around the
corner you're one click away from
disaster better step it up now you
better be
great and perfectionism and I read this
and it's like you know ding ding ding
you know what I mean like I got some
work to do buddy and like I'm in a much
better place with this I I'm kind of
half jesting because I I have contended
with this and overcome a lot of it but
it comes up all the time M and you know
you and I are in a business that's
oriented around certain kind of metrics
that get socially shared and you can't
help but fall into comparison even with
the self-awareness that it's not in your
best interest to do it or that it
doesn't really mean anything and here
you are writing a whole book about why
you need to stop worrying about what
other people think but there's nothing
that's going to be more provocative or
bring that up in a more acute way than
to write a book and then share it with
the world because of course you want the
book to be enjoyed by a lot of people
and you want it to be received well and
be meaningful and the irony of all of
that like how have you you know kind of
navigated that well the subtitle is not
stop caring about what people think it
is not that the subtitle is stop
worrying so the worry piece is under my
control and so I can do something about
it and so I do care about people that
are on the round table and I do care
about some others you know because they
are influential and they can open doors
and close doors so I do care and so it's
not like I'm callous in anyway or
removed or aloof or enlightened I'm not
a narciss this book is not for
enlightened sociopaths or narcissists
okay they they got a different model
that they're working on this is for the
rest of us okay so if you think about
the mechanism of fopo fear people's
opinions is that there's an
anticipation like driving up here I
could have spent a lot of time thinking
about this conversation and what you're
going to think about me and I need to be
just right and I want to be perfect and
man I'm not okay if he doesn't think I'm
okay and what is this huge audience
going to think about or I can spend my
time in another way but the anticipation
of what another's going to think is the
bulk of
fopo yeah that was really well stated in
the book it's not the negative opinion
shared per se it's the
anticipation that that might occur
thatat all of the stress and anxiety and
you know toxic brew of neurochemicals
that you know [__] us up that's exactly
right and then so the second phase is
checking so that when I'm actually now
in front of you I am reading micro
Expressions because I want to be
connected to you but I'm not doing it to
see if I'm okay I'm doing it to be okay
with you right there's a different tone
to that and so it's like checking in did
I say the right thing did I not say the
is he what's he think oh gosh he didn't
like that oh he did like he reads micro
Expressions really well like I better
really be on my game because he's going
to see through my [__] immediately
oh God and he knows the truth and
like sometimes that's you know it feels
um x-ray vision over there but it's just
we all are actually pretty good at it
you know if we care but I've spent a lot
of time sitting in rooms with people
that are highly skilled at presenting
themselves in a strong way if you will
uhhuh and being able to see through it
yeah right and and like I I got this guy
they want me to mhm when you close a
door and you're going to go do work with
a psychologist or sports psychologist
you want to grow but you also don't know
if it's safe yet so the classic rookie
mistake is like you create a safe
environment and then it's kind of
[__] talk for 45 minutes and the
last five minutes of a session somebody
walks out and they're like hey uh maybe
we should be talking about like that
time I was fill in the blank and big
trauma it's like oh man we wasted a lot
of time to get to that but anyway non
seor here so there's the the
anticipation phase is the checking in am
I okay then there's the responding phase
and I think there's five parts of the
responding so let's say that I get a
slight hint from you that I'm not okay
and this matters to me I've got to be
okay in your eyes like that I'll conform
I'll contort which is like I'll abandon
my first principles I'll laugh at a joke
that is not [__] funny to me it's
actually offensive
but I I want to be safe with you there's
a problem in this I'll start to critique
you so I'll become offensive so you
don't critique me I'll critique you or
I'll critique somebody else and you and
I can partner in that critique so now
we're closer I might uh just flat out
disconnect from you because it's just
too much I'm so afraid of what you're
going to think of me and I so value you
that I'm going to pull away and I'm just
not going to be around much so there's a
predictable handful of things that
happen when you're operating from fopo
when you're operating from a fear of
another person's
opinion the antidote is found how well
so I think the first is to make a
fundamental commitment just like
athletes do to get better and to work
from the inside out that is the number
one antidote mindfulness would be
certainly the second like learn how
you're working psychology is the study
of self that's where it starts study
yourself
know how thought one 2 and three creates
feeling or emotion a b and c like know
yourself know your trip wires know where
you speak to yourself in a way that
builds you and backs you where you can
be free to be you understand the first
principles that matter to you Above All
Else and know the thoughts and behaviors
that line up for those first principles
and if you can do that in service of
purpose you got kind of the the whole
Buffalo lined up it's a fundamental
commitment to work from the inside out
is the
anecdote this is such an Insidious thing
like I'm just reflecting on my own life
and the decades that I was sort of
unknowingly betraying myself to conform
or to do the thing that would get the
approval of my dad or my peers without
having any understanding of what my
values were or what I even
felt was authentically me because when
you live in that space for a protracted
period of time you're so Divorced with
that inner voice that the notion of even
connecting to it or listening to it
seems entirely foreign until you reach
some crisis point that forces you to
reckon with it for the very first time
and that's a very disorienting
experience perhaps that's the moment
when people find themselves in the
office of someone like yourself for the
very first time trying to make sense of
what's happening so or they're calling
their friends saying I'm [__] up right
you know or they feel really alone or
they're just privately you know
contending with it to the point of you
know severe mental issues that's right
because they're so afraid of raising
their hand that's right because we're
conditioned to look a certain way rather
than be a certain way and we are
obsessed with performance grades happen
that way Force ranked Stacks in youth
sport happen we want to give everyone an
award but really we're only kind of
interested in the winners and like it's
a tough world to navigate period And I
don't think the world is safe it is not
designed for you to be your very best
the world is quite hostile there are Bad
actors there's good actors there's
selfish people across most communities
it's not designed for you to flourish
and so if you're going to play the game
according to the world standards I think
you get whipped around quickly and
that's why we talk about right now
there's a human energy crisis people are
more stressed more anx xiety more
depressed more addicted more suicidal
than we've had in the last call 20 years
it's not that the external world has
changed that much it's that finally
people are saying holy [__] like I'm a
mess because I've been playing this game
this obsessed culture with performance
I've drank that poison and that's never
going to fill me and so I've been
drinking this poison for a long time who
am I and what the [__] am I doing here
and once you get down into that kind of
organizing foundational type of thinking
there is a better way to go through life
and I don't think I know a better way
other than to hit my head on the
concrete I need pain that's what I
needed and I just want to be there
hopefully for people that you know don't
fall too far to hit their head in the
concrete that it's a game over but like
that they can feel their pain and do it
in a way that is healthy did you see the
David Beckham mini do series did it's
impossible to read your book without
reflecting upon like that guy and how he
navigated in the most extreme way the
opinions of other people to basically be
able to perform at the highest level and
of all like I learned so much about this
guy I thought I understood his career
but I was shocked to discover so many
things about this human being that I
didn't know super endearing and his
level of Mastery when the entire world
turned against him is extraordinary to
be able to tune out the absolute loudest
voice one could possibly imagine and
decide that you know his motivation was
going to be internally driven and that
it was up to him and then to be able to
like show up and actually do it I mean
you must have been like out of your mind
watching I loved it yeah what a moment
for people to really see what it's like
to be on the world's stage and the risk
that goes with that they told that story
in a just a beautifully endearing way
and so yeah I watched it with my son and
my wife three of us watch that like in a
in a great learning moment you know he's
navigating the social world at age 15
right tough remember when you were 15
yeah yeah it's such a young age to be
thrown onto the world stage and you know
he's a human and there's obviously he
has missteps and it's the tapestry of
life and all its colors but for him to
kind of persevere and Prevail in the
ways that that he did was you know
really kind of a remarkable case study
for all the things that you're talking
about 100% agreed yeah the converse of
that is a story that I read just the
other day I don't know if you saw this
it was a Wall Street Journal article
about this guy Dave Hollis did you see
this no do you know who Rachel Hollis is
I know Rachel this is her so this was
her ex-husband who passed away and it's
really a cautionary tale about what was
going on in the last stages of this
guy's life um by all accounts somebody
who had a very unhealthy relationship to
other people's opinions on social media
that was driving some errant behavior
and so addicted to the metrics and the
approval that it's directly correlated
with that guy's the end of that guy's
life like he was found dead in his bed
with alcohol Fentanyl and cocaine in his
system with his phone on his chest and
it's this unbelievable cautionary tale
about the influencer economy and kind of
what social media and this outsized
relationship with approval and you know
other people's opinions like
extrinsic metrics to the nth degree can
have on somebody's mental health that
would like drive them to their death
yeah I bring that up you're nailing it
simply to say that this is like a very
real thing with very real world
consequence is it's not a small thing
it's not and freedom will not be
understood by the limited time that we
have here if we're playing the secondary
game to be approved or not rejected by
other people and so yeah thank you for
the sobering reminder of like what the
extreme looks like yeah yeah what's
happening neurochemically in our brains
when we're engaging with this fear of
other people's opinions when we're
actually in the anticip
[Music]
it's basically it looks I would imagine
we haven't done a clinical trial or
study on it but it would look exactly
like anxiety does and so you'd have that
right kind of cocktail where there's an
urgency that's taking place to get
something just right and there's the
right levels of cortical uh arousal with
some cortisol and adrenaline and so
there's all of those mechanisms in place
that amplify The Experience there's an
Attunement to get it right and it can be
actually addicting in some respects
because there's an aliveness that comes
with it and you hear people talk about
anxiety and depression they don't want
it but there's an aliveness that comes
with both of those that sometimes they
don't want to shed there's a tenderness
that can happen with some depression
deep depression like I'm talking about
mild or moderate there's a tenderness
that happens there's a an availability
to feel in ways that you haven't felt
before but you just can't get out of it
you can't remove yourself from it so
that's the opposite the anxious state
that I'm talking about the cocktail
there is that there's an urgency to get
it just right the energy level is really
high and that can feel wonderfully
stimulating but the problem is that you
can't downregulate it well and it's this
chronic elevated hum that is an
exhausting experience and then when
you're actually in the presence of the
other person's opinion that you're
trying to get favor for you get
basically whipped around by that that
intensity and it's
tiring what is the healthy version of
being motivated by the opinions of
others because it's not hard to imagine
take a quarterback on a on a football
team like I want to win for my team I
want to win for the fans or the rock is
like I do this for the fans I work hard
because I want you to you know it's like
there's something healthy about not
being utterly self-referential in why
you're doing what you're doing but doing
it for a purpose that extends beyond
your own kind of selfish regard oh I
think you're nailing purpose people can
be very clever and how they cloak
purpose you know so is the purpose
really about creating an experience for
other people where they see a better
version of themselves better to say it
that way it sounds better right so I
don't think there is a healthy version
when the primary operating system is the
need to be accepted or the fear of
rejection I don't think that that is
healthy in the becoming to be connected
to other people is the fabric of the
coral reef of humanity but when it's a
self-centered self-preserving mechanism
primarily do they like me are they
rejecting me I don't know a healthy
version but I can say you can facilitate
you can use that mechanism that model if
you will to potentially be the best in
the world at something the best in the
world often times have just enough
anxiety just enough OCD just enough
narciss ISM just enough perfectionism
where they are compelled to go the
distance and to go to the dark caves of
high performance and to suffer in those
places just a little bit longer than
anyone else will you can find yourself
on the world stage with lots of money
lots of Fame lots of attention whatever
the value proposition that you're going
for is and you literally you might be
the best in the world I'm not sure that
you're going to be healthy but it'll
take you to that place there is a better
way
you can have a purpose you can be
connected to other people you can know
that you are going to need to go to the
edges on a regular basis and have a
community of people that you're
processing with and doing it with that
is not self-centered only right but good
luck convincing that person that there's
a better way oh yeah that's got to be
the ultimate hard case right because
everything in their life has been a
successful byproduct of these unhealthy
Tendencies there's no way you're going
to disabuse that person that they should
let go of that and that there's a better
way when you know the world is just you
know raining gold upon them we did the
study my mentor she designed the study
in the NBA where um the hypothesis if
you will is that people that had a sense
of what they're going to do postc career
would Faire better while they're in the
league okay and what she was going to do
is provide a quick little questionnaire
like what do you want to do next and
then if they said I want to be a pilot
well then the team was going to figure
out how to get offseason some pilot
lessons or you know hook them up with a
pilot that could show them the ropes or
whatever so there's a little bit of
internship slash harvesting of what that
thing could be all right I can't
remember the exact numbers but let's
just say it was an equal split I don't
think it was that people said oh I know
what I want to do it's pilot versus
people said why are we talking about
this I'm here yeah I can't indulge in
that are you kidding me to even imagine
what comes after is going to undercut my
ability to be the absolute best in this
very privileged situation that I find
myself in right now and so in that group
there was two main narratives one
narrative was I I can't afford that time
like I'm hanging on and I'm going to do
everything I can to be here it's a short
window I'm all in here I'll deal with
the consequences of not knowing what the
hell I'm going to do later okay and the
other narrative was like why would I
bother I made it I'm here this is the
good life
okay so what she found and they found is
that folks that nested what they're
going to do next performed better based
on uh duration and had a better
experience when they reflected post
their time in the career wow so it was
on the folks that are like why would I
bother it was shorter and they played
with more anxiety so that's a really
interesting finding and what do you make
of that know what's next have an idea of
like where you're pointing to and the
things that are interesting and
compelling for your future go back to
almost our first part of our
conversation using your imagination to
see a future that is not time Bound by
the things that you're doing right now
but later that's a right of a passage
for adulthood is to use your imagination
in a in a powerful way and I a th% agree
because when everything's kind of
rolling and the train is going it feels
like it's going in the right direction
even me I'm like wait wait wait wait
wait hold on this is working now and so
it's hard when that energy is taking
place to be thoughtful about later and
maybe even a Divergent path so this is
where that Insight that I've shared with
you before is that the reason people
change is because of pain and how we
grow is being uncomfortable and so just
kind of be ready and open you know when
there's the pain that's there and
sometimes if people want a relationship
with you you can help induce pain I'm
talking about emotional pain the honesty
of like feeling what it's like to be
unsettled um but that's for the
brave yeah that's a whole different
thing that's a different deal yeah kind
of raise the standard before you
actually hit your head on the concrete
right I want you to tell the story about
the other mentor of yours because it
gets into a whole other new area that I
want to explore with you I should
separate these two out because my
deepest longest richest Mentor his name
is Gary DeBlasio and he's known me since
I was 15 years old and he's been there
for all the versions of me that's not
the other Mentor I'm mentioning now
which I mentioned in the book so this
was a a professional mentor and he was
one of the reasons I went to the PHD
program I went to and he helped me a lot
I learned a lot from him and I'll keep
him nameless I learned a lot from him
and he trusted me and he got me going in
the field and it was a I have such
regard for how much he helped me and so
some time had gone by I was in my career
kind of like maybe 10 years into it I
don't know exact numbers and and I was
working with a professional fighter in
the UFC and we did a great Camp it was a
three-month Camp it was a head coach it
was me and a strike coach and we did
some great work together with the
athlete and he had a championship fight
we practiced everything pre-rehearsal
the night before full R rehearsal where
we walked through everything and and not
including all the three months of real
work you know time under retention every
day on mindset Technical and physical
training including whose hands he's
going to shake what is the walk out to
the
Octagon all of that yeah to the point
where when he would walk up the five
steps to get into the Octagon like we
got all to that to the details you were
talking about but we didn't practice
where we were going to go so I just
followed the head coach so the athlete
goes into the Octagon all that was
dialed in but I hadn't taken care of
myself yet
okay so I follow the coach this is now
unfolding with I don't know 18,000
people in the arena and that all that
kind of Buzz energy and I'm like oh [__]
so I just follow the coach up and I
actually didn't know where our Corner
was what we were supposed to do so I
just follow the head coach and as we're
walking up the the same five steps that
the athlete did we have to cut in the
line of the camera and I follow him and
he's like yeah right here we're here and
so okay now I'm at home and so the fight
happens great event on my way home my
mentor calls and I was like oh man like
maybe he saw the fight or something i'
like or maybe it was just checking in I
don't know but I didn't know what was up
but he says goes okay nice job dude but
what are you doing in front of the
camera like get yourself in the
background like that's not where we're
supposed to be and he didn't say all
that he just gave me a quick little shot
that says um what are you doing in front
of the
camera and then I internalized all of it
created this narrative I've let him down
I've let the industry down I'm breaking
a rule I'm not supposed to be here I'm
maybe I'm not even supposed to be at
public events where there is cameras
because psychology happens in the back
room not in the front room and it was
really unsettling it was a problem for
me and I wanted to bring psychology
forward this beautiful science to help
people be at home with themselves
wherever they are and I wanted to bring
it forward and I wanted to share like
how the best in the world work and then
I just felt like I got got punched so I
retreated to the to the background and I
thought I don't want to look bad in
front of him I don't want to let him
down and I certainly don't want to do
something becoming for the whole field
of professionals that I respect does his
perspective represent yeah the entire
Fields perspective on what you're doing
well he was so big in my life like of
course it did you know like he was big
in my life and so I just got small I
retreated to the background still doing
loving my work and car ing about the
people I'm working with but I just
damped down that idea to celebrate the
psychology the process and the
psychology so much so that maybe it was
another 5 years
later I was kind of afraid to re-engage
with them so the relationship kind of
fell out and then five years later or so
I saw him at a conference and I was like
oh man he's he's out there thinking I'm
a cook and you know like he was watching
me present and while I was presenting on
stage man I had this this near panic
attack moment as soon as I made eye
contact with him I didn't put this part
in the book and I was on stage about to
be run over with emotions and I made a
decision do I shape my presentation for
his
approval or do I stay true to my
experience and I said no I got to stay
true and it feels like a hero moment but
thank God i' done all this inner work
like for 20 plus years to be able to
navigate that moment cuz I'm certain
that if if I hadn't done the work I
would have shaped it for
him and after I got on stage and kind of
that that post glow happens that there's
a I don't want to say a line but there's
a gathering of folks that want to talk
to you you know exactly what I'm talking
about and he was kind of nested in the
back of that room disinterested in
me and so after I don't know 20
conversations or so the room had quieted
down and I walked over to him and there
was only like 50 people in the it was a
small audience I walked over to him and
and I was like oh he never cared once
just like that driver I was telling you
about earli in the conversation like I
made this story up he didn't bring it up
he probably didn't even know he was
probably really disappointed and hurt
that I had gone away for 5 years and I
had like abandoned all the trust that he
had shared with me for one [__]
comment that I made up the magnitude of
that to be something that shaped me in a
way that I just didn't want to blow it
again MH and so man feel sorry for him
and I haven't squared the relationship I
still haven't yeah you talk about seeing
him and how you know he's this Larger
than Life figure in your Consciousness
but in fact he was sort of frail and
yeah you know kind of a bit of a sad
sack in the way that you kind of
describe him in that context and so much
so that you didn't even bring it up to
him like CU you were planning on like
I'm going to go and talk to him about
this so we can clear the air and then
realizing like there's not even any
point to doing that I still had like a
little bit too much fire in me about it
you know I still wasn't I wasn't healed
from it in any way and probably not as
I'm talking to about it now only because
I I feel sadness and remorse on how I
treated myself and how I treated him and
at the same time I haven't honored that
experience with him but the story is
potent and Salient because it brings up
the extent to which we Empower other
people people in irrational ways that
end up dictating Big Time life decisions
in our own life and you know these
individuals who kind of lorded over us
in conscious and unconscious ways that
you know Bend The Arc of Our Lives
unnecessarily and then to develop an
awareness that yes you know you have not
been at the helm of your own life and
you've you've given this person so much
power and for what you know exactly is
to you know to help us realize and you
get into this in the book book like how
we over index on other people's opinions
and we we don't realize that you know
everyone's walking around self-obsessed
we think that they're judging us and
thinking about this they're thinking
about their own lives they're not
thinking about us at all just like the
car that pulled up to you right when you
were 16 and all the social science
supports this and then on top of it we
have all these cognitive biases around
thinking that people see the world that
way that we see it or that they're
understanding Us in the way that we
think they're understanding us and all
this stuff it's this weird stew that
just is like vaseline on the lens of our
of how we perceive the world oh the
color of your language right now yes yes
yes all of that and I just feel so
excited that you're seeing it in this
way because I'm like yes yes yes that
it's how I lived it I've seen a lot of
people live it and there's good science
to support it and one one of those bits
that you're talking about is called the
spotlight effect Thomas gillich at a
Cornell did a ran a really interesting
bit of research where you know was dubb
the spotlight effect because we are
walking around thinking that the world
is looking at us is my hair okay is my
shirt okay is are my words okay when in
fact you're doing the same for you
thinking about your hair and your shirt
and your words and so we end up being
these weird kind of ships passing in the
night not really connecting because we
think everyone's focused on us it's
quite magic when you think about the
aloneness that comes with that and
that's what happened he said that thing
it was probably for him more than me and
I took it about all being me and it's a
dangerous proposition when we listen to
the opinions of others too much was that
also like layered on top of this
other kind of
maybe sense that you were breaking ranks
with your profession simply by pursuing
psychology in a different way set aside
the public Spotlight aspect ECT of it
but just to break free of this Paradigm
that psychology is about kind of
treating disorders and instead looking
forward towards how psychology could be
leveraged for Human Performance I mean
that in and of itself was we sort of
take it for granted now there's a lot of
movement and energy around this field
that you're in but at the time that you
were beginning this was still kind of a
Maverick move that I suspect the
hardened you know kind of leather elbow
patched you know Herring bone you know
jacket wearing psychologists might not
have smiled upon uh to say the least and
I still think we're in some of that
because there still is some of that keep
it out of The Narrative of what's
Happening like let me be more clear I'm
kind of dancing around my words is that
the laws of psychology and the ethical
codes there's a privilege in sanctuary
that you're honoring for that person so
everything that if you and I are doing
work stays in the
sanctuary that's called confidentiality
and privilege is the fact that we're
even having the conversation so you hold
privilege and so by law I cannot even
say that I know you if I were to see you
in a grocery store I have to pretend
like you don't exist unless you
acknowledge me MH that's weird yeah it
is weird that's weird That's not healthy
because now you're in your own world
like man I I love J and like I love the
work we're doing why is he not making
any eye contact and like I think looked
at me but so it's like this weird thing
and so you got to get ahead of it and
say hey if I see you in the grocery
store look I understand the roots of
that similar Paradigm in Alcoholics
Anonymous like there's you know
anonymity and privilege and you know
confidentiality like these are all
rooted in ideas that that that make
sense they just get they get stretched
and and kind of practiced in odd yeah in
odd ways I have this conversation with
people that if I work in a private way
with them ahead of time I'm like listen
and I say that grocery store analogy I
go I can't help myself I'm coming up I'm
giving you a hug do you like hugs I like
hugs yeah all right cool you know so I
do my best to work with you know the
natural relationships and as long the
guy who's kicked back and you know he's
like poker face like no that is not my
style yeah right no yeah we're in it
it's intense and it's fun and like and
it happens in like when I'm with a
sports team it's happening on the bus in
the hallways I purposely don't have
offices when I'm working with a sports
team so it's much more organic uh that
way
so there's a great African proverb that
you have in the book that opens one of
the chapters that says the lion does not
turn around when the small dog
barks we're so obsessed with other
people's
opinions when in truth we should be
honoring our own sense of what we're
doing and it goes to the round table
piece like yes there are certain people
you need input and we can all benefit
from getting feedback you know from
people who are worthy of that time and
energy but the extent to which we sort
of ruminate on people's opinions that
don't matter is insane I think that
that's a good way to say it and often
times if you think about the analogy
between feeling like a puddle versus the
ocean and this is an ancient kind of
zenen is like be the ocean but often
times we feel like a puddle and somebody
anybody in this case could jump in with
two feet into your puddle and displace
you completely and you're completely
kind of turned upside down if you will
but when you feel like the ocean and you
are that type of magnitude and and
breadth and I mean a tanker dropped in
the middle of the ocean is not really
going to displace the power of the ocean
so be more like the ocean be more like
the lion than the Barking Dog or the
puddle and that takes practice that's
part of what the inner work is is to be
more like the ocean the mountain you
know the the lion as opposed to
something small that's easily displaced
part of this practice or a practice as a
way into kind of connecting with these
ideas that you suggest is contemplating
your own mortality oh yeah I mean it's
been around a long time yeah but um yeah
it's a good way the stoics but I like
the Tyler Duran
example of him jacking up the
convenience store guy like he everybody
who's seen Fight Club he goes in and he
robs the convenience store clerk and
takes his wallet and asks the guy what
he wants to do with his life he says a
veterinarian but he abandoned it or
whatever and what does he say he's like
I'm taking your license I'm going to
come back in six months if you're not a
veteranet I'm going to kill you and
Edward Norton's like I can't believe you
did that and Tyler Duran's like what do
you mean it's the best day of this guy's
life right like he now knows he's got a
real choice to make and I love that like
I've had a practice for a long time that
I also share in the book that when I say
goodbye to people I want to practice the
fragility of relationships so now it's
going to be weird you're gonna when we
say goodbye you're going be like oh I
know what he's doing yeah but when I say
goodbye to you I'm going to mean it like
I don't know if I'll see you again and
that gives me just a thin slic moment to
honor our friendship and the time we
spent and it also prepares me in a
practice way for the next engagement I'm
going to have with somebody else the
next relationship the next conversation
to be all in it with them too MH so it
can sound morbid because one of us is
going to die at some point the time that
we have together I want to make sure I'm
in it because I don't know how long
we'll be able to do it together so I
just practice when I say goodbye like I
hope I see you again you know and like
if this is the last time how does that
go when you do you go out in the world
and you do that with you know people
that don't know you as well it's quiet
they probably don't know it's it's for
me not for them and it's to prepare me
better to be highly focused highly
attuned in my relationships with people
because that time is precious yeah who
in your mind like I guess I don't know
in the sports world is a an amazing
example or practitioner of these ideas
somebody who is just on their game in
full connection with their Mastery with
a healthy relationship with their own
value system and purpose um detached
from the unhealthy side of being
influenced by other people's opinions
like who's out there like rocking it I
don't know who to point to like really
yeah I don't know who to point because
you must watch sports like a film
director watches movies where you're
just you're seeing with x-ray vision
you're kind of looking at at it
differently and I've been privileged to
be in the inner workings of so many
lives that have been the best in the
world at what they do and I think some
have done a really nice job and I'll
tell you who I want to put on the
pedestal here to answer your question is
I want to put Alex and old there and I
want to put him there but I don't know
well enough the actual fabric of his
relationships with his loved ones I
leave it a little open I think he's the
most significant athlete in our era I
think he's the one that I think about
that
is done and moved into territory that
the rest of the world thought was
incredibly stupid or dangerous or could
not be done and so I have great regard
and respect for that but I don't know
the fabric of his relationships with
others I think his relationships with
others are pretty good I mean he's a
very unique individual not just as an
athlete but psychologically I think it's
a great choice because if you really
look at this guy like his internal
barometer or Compass is just super
attuned like he knows who he is he knows
what he's doing he knows what he's
trying to achieve and he's not unaware
of the world's perception of him but it
doesn't seem to at all Impact him in any
kind of negative way like his connection
with his Northstar is
like impenetrable yeah sounds like
you've had a chance to spend some time
with him a little bit I mean not a ton
but he's been on the show a bunch of
times same here and like I think he's
the most significant athlete of our time
and so I love that you have that texture
which I don't quite have for him I hope
so that's that's really right that's a
good choice I like that see you were
like I don't know how to answer that and
then you just rocked it with an awesome
Choice yeah so who do you put up there
oh yeah throwing it right back at me um
wow it's hard to top Alex I mean I would
think I'm not
like watching a ton of sport so you're
probably catching me off guard I mean
who else would
be I think what KY Lenny is doing right
now would be there as well you had him
on as well right Kai is a special human
I think he's the he's the new leader you
know he's not the like look at my brass
that I've shined up he's like I'm a
learner I'm a beginner I'm an Explorer
and he is rad you know from the soul out
he is awesome I love that choice MH I
really I pulled that my ass nice job
nice job this idea of
being in kind of emotional connection
with our own mortality and kind of
understanding the temporality of
everything and The Limited you know kind
of lifespan that we have and how we all
kind of squander time I mean this is our
greatest resource and it's the one we
least protect right we can understand
that intellectually and we can read the
stoics and we can listen to Steve Jobs
give his commencement speech and do all
that kind of stuff but for some reason
the human brain has difficulty
Translating that into kind of any real
palpable emotional experience like it
seems to fade quickly that's right like
what is that why can't we just hold on
to that and bring that into our
conscious awareness yes I can say to you
when you leave I hope I see you again
and mean it and mean it but I'll snap
right back to you know whatever [__]
is like circulating in my mind if you
practiced it for a week with every time
you said goodbye to someone and you
meant it you'd be closer to honoring the
fragility of the relationship and you
would be more tuned this is maybe one
reason Alex is so tuned because he knows
that mistakes cost lives and he's lost a
lot of friends and so he's probably more
tuned than most of us because he works
in highly consequential environments and
so we don't practice it I got snapped
back by a musician and I was like man
like pH if I could just like that's
amazing how you can sing and he says um
have you practiced I was like no I think
I'm toned deaf he goes yeah but have you
practiced and I'm not toned deaf but you
know like I can't hit a note and he goes
yeah but how much time do you practice
no no no I don't practice but like he's
like this is like a kind of a stupid
conversation so I'm not saying that to
you I'm saying like you we don't
practice it and that real denial of
fragility of life serves a purpose
because we could be overrun by just how
fragile life is and all we do is kind of
you know Niche down in such a way that
we don't do very much we don't explore
we don't leave our kids side you know we
don't leave our spouse aside because
like we want to be with them and they're
the ones and so it can it can become
overwhelming so I think that the denial
mechanism there is serving a dual
purpose right that idea of practice we
look at somebody who can sing well and
we just believe that that's God's gift
to them and it's just they came out of
the womb that way and we don't
appreciate that it's its own Act of
Mastery over many many years we don't
have that same relationship with other
people who are good at things we
understand it took a long time for them
to get there but with certain talents
yeah we have blind spots around that and
you know similarly you talked about the
evolutionary kind of underpinnings of
these fear impulses but the other piece
is the learnability of all of this so
when practiced you know there's this
well I'm just wired this way like I
can't help it like I'm just you know I
can't help thinking about all these
other people what you're saying is no
there is a method that if you practice
it you can kind of transcend this
crippling thing oh 100% like we can get
better a lot you know where do we put
our gaze and our attention and our time
and what resources will we muster to get
better at something and honestly like I
am totally um biased in what I'm about
to say but I cannot imagine the path of
becoming your very best in this limited
time unknown amount of time that we have
without having somebody in your life
that is as unbiased as they possibly can
to commit to seeing you supporting you
and challenging you and that's their job
that's their role I'm describing what I
would consider to be a great
psychologist and if that feels
unavailable for whatever reasons
somebody your life that commits to
seeing you supporting you and
challenging you to be your very best
paid or unpaid is a radical accelerant
you can do it on your
own it's harder right you can become a
better version of yourself not having to
rely on another person to help you we
are more like a coral reef than we are
the hammered nail but one of the dangers
in life is thinking that I need someone
to act or do something for me to be okay
so one of the great insights is to not
have the other person love me but
actually for me to give love to others
and so the directionality is significant
and so we become powerful when we know
how we want to be in life and
relationship with others and we're not
dependent on the other person being just
right or just so so I just can't imagine
how to become one's very best without a
partner in that process mhm yeah because
the accountability piece the necessity
of honesty and the kind of mirroring
back you know to point out your blind
spots like you can't perform this in
your own mind because you're trying to
solve a problem with the same mind that
created it right which is like an old
Trope right like you and and part of the
process of getting better and and
transcending these patterns and
identifying these blind spots is a bit
of a surrender like you have to
surrender that illusion of control that
you believe you have over these things
and that requires vulnerability and a
level of honesty that's uncomfortable
but that's part of it in and of itself
just the act of being able to be
vulnerable and honest with another human
being and trusting them is like half the
game yes you're Al together it doesn't
even matter what you're saying like like
you have to be able to do that in order
to even get to the part that's the acute
problem that you're trying to solve so
every year my inner circle and the the
team at finding Mastery would do the
year of and so it's an individual
promise that you're making it's not a
resolution but it's like an intention
and a focus for the year and so for me
the last two years in a row because I
didn't quite have the experience I
wanted on the first time this year 2023
was the year of play and I wanted to do
it more like a panda bear I wanted to go
through life like I didn't have
predators out there and I could be free
and big and play and like the year of
play and so my wife is committed to
helping me be my very best and I am in
in return to her as well and so when
blind spots are are noted I can be
defensive or I can be more like a panda
and that was the kind of the image that
I wanted to have when she says hey
whoa really you know and there those
moments like how many times and so the
way I want to do it is is a good example
is so she gave me a moment where she was
like Hey you you're saying one thing and
doing another my reflexive nature is
like really you know like like defensive
right and so this moment that we had and
it was that and and I said oh God I'm
trying so hard thank you thank you and
I've got this big smile and I just
wanted to inhabit being a panda with her
and she looks and she's like oh I got
diffused like okay cool you know and so
now I'm you know like so I just think
this idea of being playful in these
these relationships is materially
important and um I'm an intense serious
person and I like that but I want more
range and I want more Dimension and I
want to have more fun and I want to play
more and so I just bringing this up
because it doesn't have to be so serious
right that's a really good point wow
that's interesting so what is 2024 then
we're not quite there for you I don't I
might do it again like the year of play
again I've really liked it and so I feel
like I've done pretty good at it and I
think I can still get better and so when
we first met you inspired me I haven't
shared this with you it was the year of
roots and
reach and so it was after we met and so
Roots be grounded stay true to your
roots a meditative practice about Roots
being connected to First principles all
of that was is still something I do on a
regular basis but then I was going to
extend out to reach because I wanted to
build a community of people that are
exploring and sharing and I'm going to
share and celebrate how some of the
brightest Minds like you work from the
inside out the brilliant psychology of
Excellence roots and reach not just
reach not just Roots but roots and reach
I did that for like four years in a row
and so you were part of that that
inspiration cool yeah well you inspired
me towards play like I'm just walking
around grinding my teeth you know like I
just you know I need a lot more
levity relationship to like everything
that I'm doing I get overwhelmed and
then I get grave about everything and
obviously that's it cross purposes with
the kind of experiences that I'm trying
to create here and everything right you
know sometimes it's hard to connect with
that Joy or you know what it is that
inspired you in the first place to even
do this holding on to that yeah like I
need a an accountability partner on my
round table for that right can I solicit
you for that 100% yeah all right back
and forth I appreciate you one more
thing we round it out obviously you're
somebody who believes deeply in the
human capacity for change for positive
change I think a lot of people walk
around lacking a sufficient appreciation
for their own agency to change their
lives so in parting I think it would be
instructive to share a few thoughts just
about about that capacity like what is
the nature of change and what is the
best way for somebody who's thinking
about or on the precipice of of trying
to access a better version of themselves
like how do they begin to think about
what this could look like and take the
first step into practicing it very cool
if people knew what I
knew based on my unique life experiences
and what I've studied and the rooms I've
been in with some of the leaders of
human potential they would know this
single idea we are capable of so much
more more and there is so much more room
to grow to give to build to become and
this becoming to have a love affair with
experience like we talked about before
and to have a love affair with who you
are becoming more often it's awesome and
we are capable of so much more and I
would just start with like thinking
about what you are capable of like what
does the good life mean to you and using
your imagination in that way is where
this begins and if you can have some
some Partners along the way that
understand it with you it does get
easier because it's easy to slide back
to the habits of thinking that you've
developed over your 20 40 50 years of
life and part of the change whatever
change you want in your life is changing
how you think is changing how you behave
and that is not an easy thing to do to
change your thoughts because they're
invisible so I need to make them public
and I need to be clear about them first
to myself and then clear with other
people that have my back and will
support and challenge me in that order
and so start with your imagination about
who it is that you want to be and who
you want to become and um so much as
possible we must put in real work to
create the skills and capabilities for
that version of you to become and then
I'll add one more component which is um
just for fun how many versions of you do
you think you're on what version of Rich
are you
on well there's broad slicing and thin
slicing yeah you know let's go let's go
broad let's go kind of big versions
let's
see I think version four I love okay so
most people do somewhere between four
and six mhm and it's really interesting
people don't say like 200 or 50 it's
like somewhere between we've had four to
six massive upgrades or versions of our
CS now there's a 4.1 a 4.4 whatever but
so you're saying version four and then
maybe one way to think about next the
Turning of the leaf of the new year is
is interesting time but if you thought
about
V5 what is V5 it doesn't need to be
V10 but what does V5 look like and use
your imagination to push right to the
edges where you're like is that really
possible for someone like me who's had
you're about 35 right about 35 years of
trauma experience like 25 years of that
but go ahead me too yeah so so like is
that really possible and then sharing
that with your inner sanctum that's a
it's a pretty cool way to do it and so
what does V5 look like maybe make that
commitment the year of as the primary
capability that you're trying to build
for V5 to be honest and true in Quiet
Moments and consequential moments that's
a great frame I've already done some of
that but I think what you shared kind of
brings it into focus in a technical way
where I have like a context to drill
down on it in a more meaningful way cool
so thank you thank you this is great man
yeah it's really fun you're so good at
this podcasting thing thought about
starting a podcast I learned it from you
yeah finding Mastery podcast anybody
who's listening to this probably is
already you know listening to your show
as well but um you know Michael your
show is a gold mine and the work that
you put out into the world and just your
spirit and Sensibility the way that you
share and kind of comport yourself with
what you do I think is really kind of a
remarkable thing and I commend you for
that I'm inspired by your example and
I'm a fan and uh if there's anything I
can do to further put further wind in
your sale uh I'm I'm always here for
that so thank you that is not lost on me
at all and so thank you for thank you
for that thank you for so much that
you've already done absolutely and the
book is great the first rule of Mastery
stop worrying about what people think of
you available everywhere USA Today
bestseller and uh perennial bestseller
I'm sure app time will tell yeah I loved
it and uh it's just a great way in to
start thinking about Mastery in a way
that I would like I would have not have
thought this would have been your first
book but I'm so glad that it is because
I think like I said at the outset it
just cast this wide net that allows
everybody to come in you know and
there's this welcome that awesome body
can relate to it's a great way to hear
about it so thank you all right man
until uh until next time very cool cool
cheers
peace that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. roll.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcast on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and Shar
in the show or your favorite episode
with friends or on social media is of
course awesome and very helpful and
finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davy Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt traper p and
Harry matys appreciate the love love the
support see you back here soon peace
plant
[Music]
namaste
oh